i want to like this show
i do but how can i when clearly no one
cares about a child's eye protection
there's so much sand and wind very
dangerous
being horny i'm no expert on crash
analysis but i find it hard to believe
that the child stops rolling after a few
tumbles they were flying at top speed
shouldn't the kid be like a green
bowling ball tumbling tush over teeth 16
miles into the desert
again no expert wait
don't hurt the child considering the
crash moments ago should have
eviscerated greenies tiny bones i don't
think exhaust pipe eyes cares all that
much about hurting things
if you put one mark on him there's no
place you will be able to hide from me
but two marks means you could hide in
plain sight so don't ask about that
because it really ruins the threat
acting casual about straight-up murder
looks like
someone's gonna be going home
empty-handed silly peli ants don't have
hands
tarsal claws sure but hands do we have
amanda walks into a bar cliche
cause i feel like we need amanda walks
into a bar cliche
i believe amanda is strong and tough and
has a constitution score of at least
20. i do but this man has been hauling
equipment across a hot landscape for at
least 12 minutes and i'll be damned if
anyone wouldn't immediately drop it when
they arrive at a location where lounging
is encouraged
show off you cover us call this round he
said
believing anyone involved in a card game
i'm calling amanda bull
what's the bet 500.
grabbing exact change more importantly
did you bring back any of that dragon
meat
and despite that hunk of meat being
nowhere on his person earlier he's
surprisingly somehow
impossibly and inexplicably has meat
if you jump into hyperspace they'll die
oh
i will give all the sins back if he
drinks the lizard boba tea right now
no no no no no okay so technically that
wasn't drinking them all
but here you murderous adorable little
bastard
sleeping through your alarm carson can
you switch over to channel two
come on carl work on your subtlety how
about a code or something
it will take a moment to analyze your
ping also release the purple unicorn
that's gonna work so much better trust
me we will fire
i repeat we will fire they will not oh
look a massive canyon that can be used
to outmaneuver those who are chasing you
what a unique idea that we have never
seen before hold on
i mean thank god you told lizzy
salamander to hold on
before this she was all like wee no
hands because strapping your cargo in
during flight is apparently a man don't
pause the show everyone keeping track of
mando's weaknesses needs time to write
plummeting into
ice cave slash body check onto flight
console
and yeah it's shocking when you consider
all the other damage he's taken and
managed to stay conscious
but that's a separate list
or turn on the heater what the hell are
you doing
right this is not the time for karaoke
so the salamander frog lady grabs her
precious offspring and heads off into
the frigid cold without a clue of
dangers or direction
because that seems like the best way to
preserve your lineage
also if manda was tracking a heat source
here how would a footstep in snow
maintain heat like this
does the creature perspire some sort of
heat trapping slime and if so why would
she ever worry about staying warm in the
first place
bobbing for boba otherwise known as boba
fetch
how many spiders are too many spiders
here why wait to run
sure the frog woman isn't ready yet but
she's putting wet clothes over her wet
body so she's going to freeze to death
anyway
she survives that
go go go back to the ship super great
advice
curious why this wasn't the instinct 30
seconds ago but hey dramatic tension
isn't as fun if we're not running from
spiders directly on our heels
rather than oh i don't know having a
pretty great lead i realize now that
when i said
fire would help that i wasn't specific i
mean actual flames mando
not pew pew weaponry firing at this
point they are surrounded by t4
rangelas and while i want them to
survive they should be pounced upon and
bitten dozens of times over
look at them all but also the way this
show is falling into an x-filesy monster
of the week thing is kind of amazing and
continues to make this show one of the
best things out so
take your sin off the only reason i'm
sending this moment is because it took
him
this damn long to get out the blowtorch
and yes i know i send him for not doing
it earlier and now i'm sending him again
for doing it and you might say that's
not fair to which i would reply hey
welcome to the channel hope you enjoy
your stay
and then i'm adding another one for
putting the blowtorch away again because
i can
this little is just thinking about how
to eat all these spiders and if their
flesh is as delicious after a blaster
has ripped it apart
this area should be littered now with
dead crispy ice spiders and on behalf of
the child who would eat them all ice in
you for emitting mando's climb over
their pyre
it's pretty cool that all their gunfire
hits only the tiny targets and not the
massive ship behind it
i see their lasers are set to incredible
arachnid accuracy
inner accuracy you have an arrest
warrant for the abduction of prisoner
x-6911
noice how has no one said put down your
weapon yet
for being the rescuing sort they sure
are okay with leaving people to die
don't you be fooled this little [ __ ]
is thinking about cracking off a mammoth
spider leg as a snack
because apparently to him the entire
universe is one big episode of the great
bithish baking show
or you know fly out the way the other
guys came in
[Music]
i'm gonna be ticked if this show somehow
retcons this whole thing into some sort
of plot where he's actually
saving these eggs and not eating them
because honestly the child who even
after told not to
will continue to eat your babies with a
smile is exactly the kind of star wars
content i'm here for
but since i can't know for sure
how dare you point at me you were
pointing first make sure you click that
bell icon
but clicking the little bell icon is how
you make sure you get notified every
time we release a video so click it
dusty everyone knows one down
don't drink any more of that boba it can
clog up your intestines
i thought honoring one's word was a part
of the mandalorian code
i guess those are just stories for
children
shade the girls
[Music]